we live in an amazingly uncertain world
what's going to happen with Europe
what's going to happen with our economy
what's going to happen with sales in the
next six months we'll try to be strong
will you be strong what will happen with
housing the problem with uncertainty is
it keeps you frozen it doesn't let you
move forward doesn't give you any
confidence so in an uncertain world I
have to ask myself what am i certain
about am i certain of nothing and the
answer is you can be certain about so
much it's unbelievable
for example right now it's winter I'm
certain it'll be spring followed by
summer by the way I have that certainty
because there is a science of cycles
there's over 300 known cycles weather
cycles business cycles biological cycles
that give you a complete handle and
accurate forecasts of the future as a
matter of fact economists have been
trained in the science of cycles but if
you notice the economists have been
really wrong lately why have they been
so wrong they're using the science of
cycles after all Warren Buffett is the
richest guy in the world because with
the science of cycles he knows when the
stock market goes up he's going to sell
and when it goes down he's going to buy
which is probably the opposite of most
other people that's why he's rich so is
there another kind of change you have to
ask yourself and the answer is yes and I
call it linear change unlike cyclical
change when linear change hits we're not
going back once you got a smartphone
you're not going back to a dumb phone
once the people in China parked their
bicycle and get a car they're not going
to say gee let's get rid of the car and
go back to the bike once people in India
get refrigeration for their home they're
not going to say we don't need
refrigeration now these are one-way
they're not cycles one-way linear
changes that have profound and amazingly
predictable consequences so in a world
of uncertainty I have to ask am i
certain of anything and create a list of
certainty the reason is because strategy
based on uncertainty as high risk
strategy based on certainty has low risk
and high reward so we are bombarded with
all of this uncertainty create a list of
things that you can be absolutely
certain about
let's give you a technological certainty
as a good example state the iPhone how
about the next iPhone I know we just got
our new one but what about the next one
could you say anything about that you
know anything about that hey no one's
left that in the bar lately and the
answer is oh you know all about the next
iPhone for example will it have a faster
processing chip in it than the current
one and the answer is of course it will
are you certainly out and doing that
with technology for 40 years called
Moore's law
we have 3G wireless now we're getting 4G
Wireless is that it or might you be able
to predict what they'll call the next
one the answer is of course it'll be 5g
followed by 6g I've been track on that
for over 30 years it's fully predictable
on a curve you can just see it right
there and can we get more in that device
or is it full can't get any more the
answer is of course we can store more in
that device it's on a similar curve to
Moore's Law going up like this very
predictable so if you look at all the
things that you can be certain about you
will find amazing possibilities and
amazing opportunities as you look at the
future spend an hour a week unplugging
from the present yeah why because it's
more related to your past than your
future you know there's a reason your
windshield is bigger than your rear-view
mirror hey let's start looking ahead a
little bit the more you look the more
you see the future is more visible than
you might expect
make a list not of the things you're
uncertain about but the things that you
are certain about first of all the
cycles what are the cycles that we know
what are the cycles the sales cycles the
business cycles by the way if there's a
sales cycle hint don't abide by it
iOS go the opposite of the sales cycle
because I want to have the deal closed
before the cycle begins but that's just
me anyway take a look at the cycles make
a list of those things we know when
Father's Day will be we know when
Christmas will be when they will the
next election will be make a list of all
the things that you know and look at the
problems and predictable opportunities
secondly look at the certainties of
linear changes what are those major
linear changes that are taking place
right now and make sure you notice them
and pay attention to them for example
your Menken
ughter is becoming what it's your
smartphone and just recently the Chinese
have been able to make a smart phone at
the same cost as a dumb phone why would
you want to make dumb phones when a
smart phone is the Internet it's a
camera it's photography it's connect
television it's radio these are profound
linear changes make a list and then look
for opportunities and put your business
strategy against those certainty lists
and you'll find low risk and high reward